Yeah, well we can we can hop off zizek I was just saying because I just have it's like one of the
only physical copies of a book I have so I'm like every now and then I just pick it up all my books
are still in columbia and I've yet to get them back here but but yeah are you planning to stay
are you planning to stay up there for the summer? Well, it I'll probably be here most of the time I
want to get back to get away from my folks for the most part but um but you got your girlfriend up
there too? Yeah, my girlfriend's here and she can't she can't really be in columbia so it's a little bit
difficult um if I get there is there a warrant out on her down here or something? Yeah, yeah she didn't
file her taxes in in south carolina so yeah um no well if I get the balinski then then I can basically
be wherever right? I don't have to be in columbia so I then I might just take away my apartment I have
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Your hair's getting long nathaniel man you're getting you're like getting close to
afro phase. Look at that. I know it's a good look. Yeah, it's like it's like chia pet. It like goes out
like that's exactly what it is. This is why I've never grown out my hair because this phase I just
know I have to get through it. I've never and it's like it's like six months. I mean that that sort of
bad phase is not it's not like a week and you're through it it's a long time and you're like I look
like a moron. That's what baseball caps are for man. Yeah, for sure. Hats will help dude. There's several
awkward phases for me and the growing it out. It's still I can barely get it into a ponytail now it's
finally just like staying up right yours has you you do the foof thing too, right? Yeah. Oh yeah, yeah, and
i'll have the the fro for a while in the early stages everything yeah mine's getting crazy long
now at this point too. I mean it's like well back down my back. Oh wow, look at that shit. I mean it's
it's really the other thing is my head's too big for hats, John. I assume that you have the same problem.
Yeah, I do. I do with most hats. Everyone's like for for whatever reason the masters tournament there the
hats that they make there just fit perfectly so I have like eight masters tournament hats and that's
pretty much what I wear. Like I'll wear a hat if I need it to keep the sun out like if I'm working or
golfing or something like that but right it is not a good look on me. Yeah, I have a pretty massive head
too and now with the hair it's even none of my hats fit anymore but I I try to use them to press
back my hair because that's the only way to get it to look like normal instead of just flying up right
I don't even know why I would bother this come this harkens back to our literally the first bit
of the first episode where we're talking about man buns the man bun. Yeah, yeah. I don't even know why
I bother with the long hair male hair care uh conversations are a recurring motif on our podcast
Yep. We're experimenting. Well, I don't know why I did either other than just the idea of
the idea of having long hair like I I had it for a year in grad school and then I shaved my head like
completely shaved it? Yeah. And uh and I think I can't even remember the incentive behind it because
I started it before covid. I mean I started growing my hair out before covid. Yeah. And then when covid hit
it covid was just made that decision super easy because I'm like well now now I don't have to
trouble over whether or not I should grow my hair out I'm doing it because I'm not gonna of the
many ways that I could get this virus I'm not gonna let getting my haircut be one of them you know that
just seems right and you're not going to see anyone through those awkward phases either that's what
you're not so it doesn't matter right so yeah I tried the beard out for a while that was an experiment
and then that was super annoying and itchy and disgusting so I cut that out and transferred it over
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, there is there's definitely a hump for the beard phase. Yeah, the neck hair is the worst
because you need at least a base like to keep the chin under and I hate this shit under here man
is this a beard yet nathaniel or is it a proto beard? It's this is just how I keep it by and large okay
that's a beard. So you keep it you you trim it then? Yeah, oh yeah, yeah. Okay, pretty close to the face
keep it close to the face. I did that a couple years ago I let it grow and it's just on some people it
looks good but for me it's just like a yeah just no the same thing with chia pet on my face. Yeah, yeah
yeah I mean like I i and again I don't know if I got it way longer that I'd be able to like I don't
know comb it or braid it or something but you know the longest it's gotten is like out to here and
it does just look like I've been stranded in the woods for months and yeah it gets a little frizzy
I found that like a beard balm will help because it kind of collects all of the flyways I did that too
more uniform but that feels gross there are no straightaways they're you know they're all flyaways
Well, then it gets fun because the last time I grew it, which was two years ago, like right here.
These two sides totally gray, like just completely gray, whereas this is still like sort of normal
colors around here, but then for whatever reason, this, this is my gray area. You go with the Wolverine look.
That could look kind of cool. Yeah, there's does Wolverine. I don't even remember the Wolverine, I
don't know, maybe. Yeah, yeah, I think he has gray sideburns, but I'm not trying to like, I've got gray eyebrow
hair, you know. I mean, it's not a good thing. It's, there's nothing possible well in the eyebrows, yeah, but
the in your regular hair, you don't look like you have any. I don't see any gray. Oh, no. Oh, I got plenty of
gray, gray, yeah. If you look closely, and uh, I can't remember who it was. A friend of mine took, was taking
pictures one day. This was uh, last summer, and it was outside obviously because of covet and for whatever
reason, just given the light and whatever the aperture was, like I looked like I had white hair.
And I was like, I'm not cool. I am not cool with that.
I mean, my the, you know, especially in the summer, my hair is really blonde, so I I don't know, like
when I start getting gray if that'll hide it or what, if the contrast is what gets you, usually
usually, yeah, the contrast makes it stand out, stand out. But I think people with blonde hair
go full gray earlier than people with dark hair. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. I think as a as a general. I mean
that's just maybe I'm wrong about that. I don't know, but it's just, it's just a guess. You won't be able
to notice it till you are fully. You won't, you won't. And people, people won't really notice it at all,
whereas like Nate's, you know, Nate gets a few gray hairs and it'll stand out. I have a ton of gray, I
guess you can't see him on the Zoom, but I have a show. No, you know, you can totally see. Yeah, you can see
him. Yeah, yeah, I don't know why. Like my my grandpa was fully white by the age of 30, so I'm guessing I'm
following in his uh, footsteps. Yeah, for some reason I won't go bald but I will be gray. My promise to
myself is that when I turn gray or white, I'm preferably white not gray, I'm growing the bigger
beard and I'm taking up smoking a pipe. It's just an arbitrary decision that I've made in my life.
I try I tried to do the pipe thing once about 15 years ago. It was like it just isn't fun. Like I
really want to have a white beard. I think that's what makes it. Maybe I was lacking the white beard. It's
got to be a combo. What's the what's the purpose of a like do you get a nicotine buzz off it or is
it just like the taste and the it's like a cigar. It's the same as a cigar. You just inhale it into
your mouth and blow it out. You don't inhale it and you'll right. So you don't, you're not like getting
a you would get like sort of a head rush, I would imagine after a while if you hit like for a
fucking hour or two maybe, but I mean, you know, you have to keep what it's not like unlike a cigar, like
the cigar you like once the cigar is lit it pretty much stays lit unless you leave it for a long time
but the the pipe you just have like anytime you want to hit you light, yeah, you got to have the fire
there and you who you blow out some stuff and then then that's it and you then let it sit or hold
it in your hand for however long until you decide to take the next you know, it really is like constant
bong hits but with tobacco.
I mean, the way I've been thinking about it just because I've had to teach business writing for the
last like few semesters, I mean, that's not something I was ever like uh, internally invested in or innately
invested in, and it's still not something that I think about daily like fucking portfolios and how to
make them better, but right you can like Nathaniel was saying, like you can sort of insert your
disposition into any teaching context or into any field. I mean, the dream would be to have your
scholarship married with your teaching in a really kind of like, you know, what's the word? I don't know.
But like in a way that is yeah, in a way that's productive in both venues and they feed off of each
other, and that's not necessarily the case with me right now with business writing because it
darida has virtually I mean you can fucking insert theory in there but they are fairly incompatible
but I don't know the question is are you going to be able to if you had to do that within a
programmatic context what kind of students are you going to be drawing in there to be able to do your
theory thing and and like you I mean at certain places of that that would probably be possible but it
you would be you would have to string and push it in ways that may or may not work within
you know the expectations of the department. Well it would be mostly in the way I've been doing it
because I don't really put it on the syllabus it would be mostly implicit like baby theory
just insinuated into every class period where I'm just feeding them some version of Derrida and I
don't say it's Derrida I'm just like giving the reading of a portfolio or some sort of business
writing document and feeding them my version of rhetoric or my version of theory uh that's
accessible enough you know where it's not like where they're not like well what I thought this was
this course and we're getting rhetorical theory right you know you're doing Derrida without talking
about Derrida right right but there's there's a point in that like I the only time I did it with
business writing I only did it for one semester and I tried to do it on this sort of like
basically business business ethics was my hook into it um and it worked okay um but it wasn't fun
for me you know like I I didn't I mean I enjoyed the idea of trying to come up with it but the practice
of interacting with the students who were simply recalcitrant they were just uninterested in those kinds
of questions and so it felt like I was pulling teeth every class and when what they just wanted was
the sort of straightforward like teach us how to write uh instructions teach us how to make a CV
and you know I mean so that's it's a question it's always going to be a question of which battles you
want to fight like you're not going to land anywhere where they want you to teach a class on Zizek and
they've got 10 graduate students who want to take it right away it's just not you're not going to have
that so you have to kind of forge that over a little bit of time but and which battles do you want to
fight and for how long and and to be honest I don't mind teaching like instrumental stuff
for a little bit because it's it's honest work you're you're giving them real advice that might
actually help them in the next few months down the road I mean students are very grateful learning how
to write a resume I mean you wouldn't like it's like oh it's very explicit like this is the payoff
of uh like you're you're branding yourself as a professional and it gives them something whereas
sometimes it's harder for me to uh to sell the the first year like 101 or 102 classes because
clearly the main pitch the way it's phrased in the on the like the web page is like we're teaching you
how to write for college and it's like okay it's still instrumental but then students don't even care
about that you're teaching them how to write for that class and that class only basically so it's hard
to what you know the writing across the curriculum you know is the big one now and it's like you're not
really writing across any curriculum you're writing for one teacher and then another teacher and then
another teacher you know I mean one of the advantages that I found working at a very small institution is
I have way more freedom than I ever anticipated that I mean you know and this isn't likely to happen
you know everywhere but like they're like there's this writing program that we have
we want someone who has a vision for it and now I only teach the classes that I wanted to teach
no like I have to think about how I've articulated this program you know in relationship to the
department and to the rest of the university but like I don't teach any I don't think I don't take
I don't think of any of my classes as service classes despite the fact that I do teach a first year
course that you know fulfills a mandatory writing course for a credit for a lot of degree programs
but you know I don't treat it as like college writing or anything like that that right is you
know I mean I have this whole sort of like practice repetition writing you know through the like
thinking through writing um yeah approach you know and we do that by the way that that's one of the
things that I think that you particularly do well is as we both know um a lot of the the sort of
conceptual stuff that comes out of the things that we're interested in thinking about involves
practices that are really traditional right which are you know sort of rote repetition and things
like that if you foreground the importance of those rote traditional things you no longer one no longer
looks like and that's what I'm saying I think that you do this well like you don't say I'm going
to take a Deleuzian approach to teaching composition you're like no no I'm going to emphasize
the ways in which repetition can produce transformation and changes and they go oh that
yes that sounds like writing pedagogy right yeah exactly I mean again I've said it a million times
but never underestimate the value of like proper like proper names and the response that they elicit
like the word to lose the word there these things have you know substantial effects on colleagues and
and others you know so for sure but the whole thing to just I mean
I mean I'm adapting you know like Barad's ways of reading with this and I do use his text for
That that class, but you know the whole approach is like I'm not like the stuff that we read I'm not
teaching you that content I'm actually like I am up front you know uh I don't care about that
as a primarily or secondary I care about it maybe like you know third down the list but the entire
function of these texts that we're going to be spending a long time with is to get used to the
kinds of moves that you can make and response to it and the kinds of moves that they're making in
response to whatever it is that they're responding to so yeah like the whole bodily imminent pedagogy
thing but that's a first year writing class and I do it yeah by reducing the number of parts we read
three texts three texts in an entire term and then they write a ton on those three texts right right
just the key just those key words that you use in order to describe what you're doing are the things
that make a huge amount of difference you know yeah that's recognizable to people outside of exactly
but you sold me on that I in fact it was going back to because I'm doing I told I think I told you the
theory undergrad um in the fall and uh I'm I'm scaling back like way back in terms of the number of texts
that I'm going to have them read so it's like like in in half um so fairly dramatic and I'm also going
to I I've been doing exams for a while and I'm going to just I just don't believe in exams other than
they're easy you know for me um and and also for them for the most part um so I'm just I'm going to
take those out as well so it's gonna my undergrad I'm basically completely remaking my undergrad theory
class into a critical thinking class like that's all it is critical thinking asking questions about
assumptions how do you do that and then so theory is just examples of ways that people have done that
that's all it is I mean like my thing is to fold you know to make it like uh just to iterate the
critical thinking thing a little bit is to add the dimension of writing as not you know the
communicative mechanism by which that's right but like the structure of it is how critical thinking
proceeds more cautiously than in talk yeah yeah um yeah uh but you know I had you know and for my
for my upper level theory course you know I had I'm having conferences this week and I'm just talking
about you know they write these things that I call invention drafts which I sometimes describes like
Frankenstein's monsters of of drafts you know if if if the good well composed speech has a head and two
arms and you know two legs you know this is this might have like three you know splings but no heart and
you know it's but anyway you know I mean two of my students who want who want to write on you know
Barth and the death of the author and the function of the reader and sort of like bringing in Foucault
and they've got like relatively smart apparatuses but I'm like look you know what I want you to do for
this because we're going to scale this back a little bit for like the first third of your paper I just
want you to get get really really comfortable with Barth's six page article and really like
explicitly tease out the distinctions he's making between the scripter and the author and the critic
and the and the reader because like you know I don't I I want you one of my students I'm like I
don't think you really have a good grasp on the sort of the turn to the reader at the end and the
impersonal what is what is the the reader without identity without the reader the impersonal reader
yeah right exactly without history right and like what is a reader without history
yeah and and so and Barth even for scholars Barth gets turned into like a reader response like I'm
reading my yeah and like it's now it's just the tyranny of the reader like I want you to know that last
page you know backwards and forwards and inside out and you know I want you to remember that what you
were doing for me as an undergraduate uh for an undergraduate class is an exercise and not you
know the production of novel scholarship and I want you to exercise understanding this and writing through
that that concept and not you know feel like you have to make the original move but then use it to you
know use these tools that you don't have a handle on well it sounds like you have some students who
are pretty interested in close reading or at least that you're trying to facilitate that I mean and
I find that endlessly productive and engaging and exciting to do but I find that only a select
few of my students per semester really want to do that kind of work you know or know how to this
is what the advantage I mean that's my that's my third year theory course and I got 10 people in the
class right by then they're self-selecting now in my first year course is when I have 20 25 students in
there you know I one I always have like I'll have like 25 students on a wait list and then I'll come
down to like somewhere between 18 and 22 because people drop when they realize you know what they're
Doing and then I have the people who are ready to do it and you know like they jump right in and then
but you know and there's the people in the middle that I kind of like convert at a certain point and they
realize that they actually have a talent and they enjoy it but I've I've installed you know versions
of that approach into every class that I teach right versions of that thinking through writing
repetition imitation you know narrow the the scope of the thing you know iterate you know responses to
the thing through every course that I teach that runs you know first through through fourth year so
you know not only as a program are students kind of self-selecting as you know they enter into this
writing minor but then they go through the first year course and then it kind of like it's built up a
little bit of I don't want to say identity but a little bit of sort of like a gravitational pull
for nice you know bringing in and cultivating certain kinds of students that I would not be able to do
if I were at a bigger institution and I was like teaching a section of like you know a hundred sections of this
course right yeah well that's cool I mean then that's one advantage of at least your institution
maybe of most smaller uh institutions in general I don't yeah I mean I that's a good question I mean
it's definitely an advantage of my institution and my faculty really is you know they were like look
here ultimately this is what we care about is that the writing program has some kind of intellectually
rigorous sort of thing that it's doing and as long as your thing you know as long as you can do that
and it's interesting then we don't care what it is specifically
that that's it actually so there's a way in which I feel like a lot of what we do we meaning sort of
English department humanities faculty is we train them that what they're supposed to do
is apply this to your life but that's still a classroom lesson right the classroom lesson is
that you have to apply this thing to your life as opposed to the like no no no you have to learn that
everything that you learn is about living yeah that's learning is a part of living as opposed to like
learn how to connect this to your life so you know don't just learn how to connect it to your life so
you can tell the teacher something and get the good grade in the class because I think a lot of the
students who are very good students they really do just they don't really make that that slight uh
he talks about it here there's a great moment look at this seamless segue uh
not seamless because I just pointed out but where he talks about the um the substituting my inclination
for death with a uh um like it wasn't a longing for death which is uh uh you know he describes it as
a jumping in place like nothing changes but everything shifts and and that's that kind I mean that really
resonated for me a lot and and I mean I wasn't specifically thinking about pedagogy but in this
context it really makes sense for me of the the difference between like I'm learning I'm learning
to connect this lesson from let's say Barthes' Death of the Author to how I think about you know something
involving my life but I'm not learning it so that I can you know mentally reproduce this thing and
succeed in the class I'm actually learning it to help me live and make decisions about what I'm going to
do in the future that slight twist you know well yeah you know it's I mean it's interesting the
student that I was having that conversation with I was I was reading this paper which is sort of like
you know um uh uh Barthes and Foucault were writing this pre-internet how to sort of like digital um
forms of writing and how other how does this sort of like um impact the way that we say look at other
mediums like say hip-hop and you know I'm going to look at say like Kendrick Lamar and sort of look
at the way that the empowerment powering of the of the reader sort of like undercuts the authenticity
of the you know racialized other like so like first I was like this is not a particularly good reading
of Barthes and and and the reader but two and this is a student that I've had for four years now and so I
feel like I feel like I know him pretty well it's like yeah what you seem to be working through is
trying to reconcile that with the fact that you really like Kendrick Lamar's music but there is a
sort of like an ickiness with feeling like you have some kind of authorial or interpretive control over
you know a um someone's art that they have you know produced from varied you as like you know white
suburban you know dude you know having a hard time with uh the Barthes the claim that Barthes seems to be
making about the empowerment of of the reader and you're concerned about the kind of like integrity
authenticity um so like let's reframe that that question a little bit like how like let's think
about how you sort of like encounter something like Kendrick Lamar's music and how does you know this
engagement with bar allow you you know sort of like at a parallel parallel level or your paratactical
you know relationship, how does this meditation on bar allow you to think through your relationship to
this music that you that you like, right? Yeah, yeah, that this is just a different way of approaching it.
I mean, no, but that's good. It is trying to use, I mean, it's trying to get that like, oh wait, this is about
actually solving the problem of what is my discomfort like? Yeah, what is the thing that's driving me here?
That's that's what this teacher is trying to teach me, so and you can't guarantee that it it hooks that
way, but yeah, yeah, I mean, you you were saying that it's kind of a slight phase shift and you're probably
right, like it is kind of a it's a barely perceptible shift from just interpreting stuff to interrogating
your own interpret interpretive framework. I think, I mean, that's something like you're saying that we
try to do every day, right? You're you're turning that over, but most people out in the world either don't
have the you know the means to do that or they've simply never encountered you know teaching or a
learning environment that would allow them, so most people, right, are just stuck in their lens of
of interpretation whereas you know people that are in our context that are actually encouraged to think
hard about stuff like it is like it's almost like most people simply don't have access to that
little phase shift that you're talking about and i did i certainly didn't. Well they don't recognize
that there are interpretive lenses right exactly like styles of reading equals styles of living and most
people are just in it, you know, but i really do think like Deleuze's uh thing here about resentiment
it's like it seems like right most people are just stuck in resentment and they they have no
not the means or the capacity to get out of it and he's encouraging not only a reflection
on resentiment but a transmutation of that entire principle and it's like
like how do you facilitate that with like the guy in my town, you know, who just works at UPS or whatever?
you know, it's like and again maybe he doesn't want to maybe we shouldn't be recruiting and evangelizing
people trying to get them to think this way i don't know it's just a confusing muck for me because
philosophy uh presents itself like this is how everybody should do this you know and what, well, but I don't
but i don't think Deleuze does like i don't think that Deleuze presents it i mean i think that's to me
the whole appeal of Deleuze is that there's not this is how everybody should do this it's just sort of
this is what happens and here's how it works um so for instance the guy there is an ethical demand at
least even if it's not like uh whatever like think about think about what the ethical demand of the the
you know the stoic sages like the sage is the one who's just going to hit you with the staff and throw
an egg at you right like well it's not the guy uh who's going to tell you how to be what i want
i want to think about though is the role of reflection in all of this because i don't see reflection
meta-reflection as having a particularly important function in not in the pages that we've read for
today no i mean clearly for Hegel like that's you know that's yeah you know that's the creme de la creme but
here i don't i mean what's the ethical demand you know the top top of 149 not to be unworthy of what
happens to us right and and resentment is you know the um the blaming of others or the blaming of
external conditions for what has happened to us and then you know like the affirmation of the amor fati
is not resignation it's like look resignation is just a form one other form or figure of resent of
resentment and sort of like teasing out the difference between resignation and affirmation
is from the ethical standpoint very very interesting here and i mean yeah but let's let's that that
claim is worth reading just because it's like it's a enormous claim it's not like either ethics makes
no sense at all or this is what it means and has nothing else to say yeah not to be not to be unworthy of
what happens to us right like so this is it's not even just like saying the principle lesson of
ethics is it's like this is all that ethics is is not to be unworthy to become not unworthy of what
happens to us um so i mean this that to me for instance i mean if you think in terms of your um
the the the the full-time working guy or whatever that you're that that are anonymous sort of real real
person or whatever that person doesn't fucking need philosophy i mean to me you know and Deleuze would
be the first to say that right there's no necessary version of like we're into it because we're into
philosophy um and we're into this kind of this discursive conceptual operation but there are many
many ways i mean he doesn't only talk about philosophers at all right like i mean there's
a book on Francis Bacon and a book on you know like it's lots of people figure out ways of creating
um circumstances that make them not unworthy of what happens to them without having any
reflexive understanding in Nathaniel's terms of of how they did that, you know, and or or what they're
doing, and so that's where to me this diagnostic operation is just that it is simply one operation
among others, not the lesson, right? It's not that here's how to it is just that we're doing it, yeah.
yeah, you're right. I mean, yeah, a firm chance, affirm the dynamics of becoming, but again, these are still
like you'd either just have to be uh dispositionally like attuned to these dynamics or you're just not
like i don't really understand. I mean, again, like the process of reading and training and thinking
makes one more dispositionally. I mean, that's Hegel, right? Like Hegel's it's the reason you have to
read the Phenomenology. You you don't just get the sort of bullet points is because it's a training
right? yeah, but I mean, I mean, I could imagine you know you said affirm the dynamics of becoming. I think
it was a really good way to articulate what's going on here. I mean, like the sense of the event as you
know, the um, you know, the uh uh the narrowest um slice of the present that like is in its is in its
state of being unformed like it is in its state of being a becoming and unfinished that is always
projecting toward something else and so to like to affirm that is to affirm one's own self-transformation at
the bottom of 149 he says you know like the this demand is to become the offspring of one's events and
thereby to be reborn like i mean to take other Deleuzian um examples like the the wasp and the orchid
do that just as much as the philosopher does to you know to like become in response to something else to
be self-transformed through one's engagements with something else you know i think of like
for some reason i've got like a River Runs Through It in my head i just imagine like the fly fisherman
you know out there like becoming in response to his relationship to to the stream which you know is
not like the that often gets articulated as like the peaceful attunement but it would have to be much
more there would have to be much more upheaval there that i like the undoing and redoing of
all elements in response to one another right? yeah, i mean the the main there's still a problem
situation here though that he's articulating right, which is resentment and if you the the one thing about
this last series that i felt and maybe he gets more into the weeds with Nietzsche later but it felt like
there was so much Nietzsche that was implicit in the 21st series that i felt like i wanted a little
more Nietzsche here um and because Nietzsche is so insistent on the the dynamics of that problem
situation right? the problem is a human problem and we've talked about this the all-too-human desire for
whatever for power for for all sorts of things that Nietzsche and by extension Deleuze sees as
the problem now i'm sure the ups got there are certain ups guys normal ass dudes who've never
read any of these people who can affirm chance right who just kind of have the the ability to do that
but it seems like the the sense is that most people can't right? isn't that kind of the assumption like
no i don't agree with that at all i would say actually quite the opposite so so to me i would say
uh resentment i mean and this is obviously i understand that this is sort of my version of
the lose's version um but resentment is just the case um and there are occasional blips that aren't that
that get uh transmitted circulated whatever they don't get translated any more in the world of
flossy than they do in the world of ups i mean they just don't right? there's no there's nothing better
about this sort of cognitive operation of self-awareness or whatever that's more likely to
encourage than anything else including the wasp and the orc including anything else so i mean so that's
that's where to me um i agree with you that resentment is the is the problem um but there
isn't a solution right? like it is simply it's like the i mean to me one of the things that i really
liked about these pages is what he does with representation uh insofar as there's a lot happening
within the practices of representation the difference between uh he calls it death mortality are the
representational sort of coordinates but dying is the thing that gets left out of both of those
um and that's but but so representation can't handle in a sense the those the dying part of things and
the dying is the impersonal right? like i mean and he's insistent upon this sort of impersonal
quality that is nevertheless like the most interior of interiority is is that um is that
impersonal part so that's where to me there's no particular content terrain that would have a
privilege on representation that's where i mean he's going after this sort of look what i mean
if you read Marcus Aurelius it's notes for how to live well right? like i mean that's it's like hey
Do this, don't do that, do that, you know, it's it's the most straightforward, like the first self-help
book, practically, right, um, and so his question here is not like should we take Marcus Aurelius's
lesson, it's what is the role of representation in the stoic ethics, which is how do we take these rules
right, um, and so on the one hand there's nothing you can do but give rules, right, like give representations
or give resentment, and yet resentment is not everything, so to me what the lesson of that is is there is
nothing but resentment and resentment is not everything, like that's the the combination of those two, there's
nothing but resentment and resentment is not everything and that is a sort of, that is that is a natural a
physical uh and ethical, that's that's where the egg thing at the beginning, it's like it's not simply a
question of eating, it's not simply a question of speaking, um, that it's the hinge that that it's the
albumin that sticks to the yolk and the right and the shell, so there's nothing superior about um, you
know diagnosing how it works, you know, yeah, I would even say that there's there's um, resentment is
invited more by self-reflection, i i would think so too, I mean because to me I think of it as like
the problem is recognition, right, like, and and insofar as recognition is the organizing movement, I mean
Hegel's again the problem with Hegel is not that he's wrong it's that he's so relentlessly right
and and so to that's the extent to which I mean what Deleuze to me is always interested in those
dimensions of non-recognition that are smuggled in through acts of recognition that are sort of you
know smuggled in, I mean that's just a term, I mean I use that phrase a lot, but that are part and parcel
of are imminent too but not the same as I mean all of those kinds of difficulties of figuring the
thing and I think the reason for doing that is precisely so that you can't say this person's doing
it better or that thing is you know it's, that's the whole reason for thinking of it as as impersonal
as unrecognized, right, the whole reason for doing all that shit is that you can't point to
it, you know, and you can't say my version of this is superior to your version, it's like my version does
certain types of things for my body in the collection of bodies around here, it won't do
that for yours, or at least you got to try it out and see, you know, I mean it seems to be that resentment
and affirmation in some ways, I always think of that, well it seems that they operate at very different levels
that you know resentment or re-sentiment, right, is only ever only ever happens at the at the level of
recognition because it requires determinate relationships between subject object verb and
especially, which is always like a moralizing of of those subject objects verb relationships, right, there has to
be you know uh something that does something to something else and then that gets a moral sense
to it, there's a good something or it was a bad something it was never just a something, but even if
it was a something there was still the the activity of the one thing striking the passivity of the other
but running imminently within that are a whole set of differential relationships that are now expressing
you know and transforming that situation that they're not operating at at the same level as well and
that's what body affirmed or denied, i'm sorry that that's what that's the only thing that can only ever
be affirmed I shouldn't say or there's no you know um
I mean this this but but affirming it doesn't mean recognizing it, right, it doesn't mean saying
ah there's the imminent intensive uh rhythm in in the terms of my book there's the singular rhythm
right, like, um, I mean that's that singular rhythms is what I was trying to think here in terms of I mean
that was my attempt to do something like sense here, you know, it was you can't ever point to it or
rather it's imminent to the act of pointing um differently in different circumstances which another way of
saying that is like in the act of pointing to the singular rhythm, right, you are representing a
asingular rhythm and then affirming a different singular rhythm, that's right, like the act of the
pointing and the recognition is one kind of affirmation that has very little to do with the
thing that you're pointing out, right, that that's right, and that's where at one level you would say
consciousness is the problem, right, like consciousness is the thing that creates recognition and self-awareness
it's the problem at the same time it's the condition of possibility for so I mean so it's it
is literally and truthfully both of them, um, so given a body what can it do, right, and and not not just like
you know try it out and we'll figure out the 17 things it's it's that is the constitutive lesson
which is you always don't know what it can do because the act of figuring it out is another body
yeah yeah yeah I mean my only it's not even I don't know if it's a reservation or a question but
if this is the case, like if there's an effort here which is explicit to affirm chance or becoming or the
event, shouldn't there, like, where you guys are basically saying there should also be an effort to affirm
resentment, right? Because if it is to some extent an inescapable dynamic, which, uh, you're attributing
to either Deleuze or Nietzsche here, it would seem like you'd have to not simply, like, because there are
parts where he's calling for the dismantling basically of resentment and of those dynamics, and
I understand that, that cut, like the need to do that, but I also, like, there's a, there's a little
portion in Jameson that I just read where he, he basically says, uh, you know, the longer you look at
difference, it, it'll, it'll turn into identity, and the longer you look at identity, it'll turn into
difference, right? And so each one just kind of morphs into the other, um, surreptitiously, and so it's
and so it's impossible to get a grasp on the dynamics that you want to get a grasp on at any
given moment in thinking or in living. So my, my only, the only reservation is just that it seems like
the target here, which maybe you can, like, use Hegel as a figure for it, it's like if he's the problem
and it's such an insistent problem, then what do you do with it? Like, what, how do you shed that basically?
You figure, I mean, the answer to that is figuring out how to live, yeah? Like, that is the whole question
that's driving the interest in the Stoic ethics here, is how do you live with that impossibility.
And I mean, what are the ways of living, and, and that's where to me it's like he's just interested
in, again, various people's itineraries through that problem of, of how to live, and that there he sees
like, oh, there's some interesting shit going on, not that there aren't interesting things going on at
UPS, they just don't write books of philosophy, you know, and so, and, and that's the particular terrain.
That's why to me there's not, it would never be a case of championing resentment, uh, or the need
to champion resentment would seem totally, it's like, to me, I think, well, what this thing, what this human
thing does is it produces, you know, consciousness, which produces recognition and resentment. That's
just the motherfucking case, and it's not going to ever be a question of more or less or great, it's
never that; it's always going to be 100% recognition, right? Not 99, 100. And yet there is something other than
resentment as well, but not as something that you can point to, but as something that is the condition for
the acting, right? So it's the action of pointing or the act, whatever. So, so here you're, we're trying to
think then of really, um, a way of thinking movement, yeah, um, that is irreducible to subject object relations to
you know, so it's, so, and it's precisely in that irreducibility that the secret, and again in giant
quotation marks, resides, because it's not a secret in the sense that it could ever be revealed; it is, it is
in the practice of the secreting, you know, uh, um. So, so that's to me, I, I feel like that's why it's a book
book of ethics in that regard, not in the sense that it's telling you what to do, even though it will
also do that, right? You don't, you don't get to have, you know, the sort of affirmation of becoming
without, again, like that, you know, you don't get to have represent, you don't get to have this sort of
singularity without representation. So it's not like let's get to the, the truth. I mean, in the conventional
way of thinking, let's get to the truth of representation, and it's in singularity, and I don't think that's the
claim here. The claim here is that singularity doesn't happen other than in or, or he, it's the event, right?
The event doesn't happen but for bodies, you know, and, and, um, and the event is never a cause,
right? And it is the impassable, and it is, so it is, it's nothing that one ever gets to, and it's
precisely that that gives it that sort of ineffable quality in this case gives it that sort of absolutely
distributed, um, component that it is, I mean, again, is everywhere in every practice in every action, so
it's as true in the UPS, yeah, circumstances as it is in any philosophy text, uh, or it says operative would
be a better way of saying it, right? Yeah, we could do, you could do that, right? You could do a kind of
Deleuzian analysis of UPS, for example, or that guy's life, or we could do those things, doing those, the
the important part would be doing those things, wouldn't be revealing anything, it would be its
own UPS operation, yeah, right? Like, it would be doing, in other words, the diagnostic operation of
revealing the singularity within the UPS operation is is its own operation, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, it just, it also just points to, and to me this is, at this level in this conversation, it's
it's more confusing than it is revelatory, but like the relationship between ontology and ethics
and does one have priority over the other. It seems like they're absolutely simultaneous
in this book, right? One cannot, one does not derive out of the other. Ethics doesn't come before ontology
The ontology is the ethics, right? I mean, if that if if ethics is just becoming and affirming becoming
then I guess in a sense every one of these words, every one of the words, like it's just and because
like every one of these words I just, I bristle at each of them, right? Like in in the question of
ethics and ontology. So the terminology in which he talks about it here is states of affairs and the event
right that would be states of affairs would be the ontological what is, right? Yeah, um, and the event will
be the ethical. So the whole book is trying to figure out and differently so in really uh uh fine-grained
ways, like what are the relate what's the relationship between bodies and events? Yeah
you know, um, and and it's not the case that it's simply it's certainly one is not simply before the
other and simply one is not like the time question. We we haven't gotten to the aeon, you know, we're
going to get to the aeon in a couple more series but it but obviously it seems like I mean he talks a
lot about a pre you know the present here that is not a present in relationship to a uh of a future
and a past, right? That is that is a I mean what does he call it? There's one place where he calls it the
pain. It's like the pain of a window, right? That it's it's it's a non-present present. Well there are
two senses of the present, right? The chronological present or the god-like present is the god-like present
yeah that's that's the eternal present where all future and past collapses into the present and that
is the expression of you know the the grand event um I I find that incredibly hard to think though not
unimaginable but like really to think of the to think of god time in that way, right? Like I mean
in other words and it makes it makes sense if I don't think about it too hard like if I don't think
about it too hard and I go okay if you're god and you can see all past and all future
time doesn't work the same way it's not even seeing all past and all future it's being all
past and all future, right? Right? Like Aquinas and stuff like that but um Augustine but um
yeah which is to say like what does you know like I mean what is change? Change in time other than
the dramatization of you know different aspects of I've just much a much larger being so if you just
are all of that then you know there's just not change doesn't happen in the same way it's all one present
everybody understands the experience of being in the zone in some capacity in some practice in their
life Deleuze's ethics is entirely how does that happen? What is that experience what what's going
on there and you know like where you're just connected to the things that you're doing in
ways that go way beyond you that have nothing to do with self-awareness except for sometimes it can
be through thinking that can be the zone, right? Like but again that's no privileged thinking
being in the zone thinking writing thinking slash writing is no real it's no different than being in
the zone and in an NBA game, right? Like it's just sort of and that experience I mean you know I think
everyone everyone that I pose that to has some sense of what I'm talking about, right? Like that sort of
sense of and it's it's impersonal and that there's something in the states of affairs and the relations
of bodies that is not reducible to those bodies because we all know 99 of the time you're not in
it, right? You're not I mean the terminology of in the zone whatever but like um that's the sense of the
event that I think that he he's after here. How does that happen? Which is not to say that that's better
than the times that you're not in the zone. It's just a different way of living and it's a way that's
worthier of what happens to you, you know? How could it because that's sort of the definition of what it
is that sort of connected connection of things think about it when you're playing basketball. That's
I mean, you know, it's been a long time but I do still remember that feeling of you know where
everyone on the court is you know what touch it's going to take to get the ball past exactly where
you want it to go, like it's just easy everything. It's every movement is easy and it's and it's not
because you're you're so in charge of things it's because you kind of give that up, right? And right
so what is going on and and to me that is that's the sense here um and it doesn't require understanding
although that's a dimension of it yeah I mean and it can be can't can be but not required I mean but
there is like you know there are sense there are a few different senses of thinking about better and
worse here and like one is sort of like failing to meet one's moral obligation as opposed to you know not
being culpable of of having failed to meet one's moral obligation but the other sense is like
I mean another sense of better and worse here is to thinking about like one's capacity to to live and
you know think about when you're not in the zone forget about like think about when you're in the
anti-zone and everything just feels disjunctive, like, just like disjointed and, you know, you're more
likely to hit someone in the back of the head with the ball than you are to, like, make the spot dime
pass. That's not fun. That, like, uh, you know, you're in your head too much or, you know, like all of the
like all of the sort of like flowing of relationships become sort of like stilted and hypostasized and
you know, like it's not just that, like, I'm different than you but like my hands different than my head
and everything. Yeah, like that sucks. What is this ball? Like, why is it shaped? What are these things
coming out of my yeah, like, oh, fingers? You would have to affirm that too, or at least you would want
to, right? At least to get past it. At least in order to eventually get past it, you wouldn't want to just
simply the issue. The issue of affirming is I think one that you're getting stuck on because what
what what is affirmed is only ever becoming. There is no affirming a basketball or affirming, there's only
like the object of affirmation is in this terminology the event. That's the only thing that gets affirmed
so the event doesn't exist as a discrete entity, so it's never a question of affirming the basketball
or affirming the body or affirming. It's always affirming the event, but affirming the bad event, right?
I mean, like, I was just there's no bad event. Well, no, but I'm saying, like, the the event where you're not
in the zone. Like, oh, yeah, of course, you would you would want to affirm that as well. And I mean this
is a kind of a dumb example, but since we brought up basketball I had a couple weeks or a couple times
playing pickup where I was in the zone or whatever, you know, in the context of all the the, you know,
mid-level players, I was playing well and was shooting well and all that and then I played with a bunch of
like lesser, like not as talented players and I I guess you ever have this happen to you where you
play with less quality people and that you go down to their level? Yes, and I was just I was bricking
shots. That's what this is exactly: just bricks, throwing up bricks every day. It was sitting there
man I had to. Yeah, yeah, I'm playing down to your level. Um, no, but I did that and I was kind of just
like I mean, we still won so maybe that's why I don't care and that's why I didn't care at the time
either, but I was just like I guess this doesn't matter. This is what always happens when I play
with this kind of this kind of talent. You end up just playing shitty and you play shitty sometimes
and you forget about it but this is also how injuries happen, right? Like, I mean, when when you're
not in the or like when when the rhythm of the playing is just so like antithetical to the way
that you're capable of of of fitting in with everything else either because you know they're just maybe
not as good as you or because they're so much better everything's happening bigger faster stronger and
you can never keep up with it like that's how people get hurt. Someone's tripping over you, you're
tripping over someone else. Yeah, and yeah, and you know in the zone because I I I don't want to move
to sort of like the zen-like attunement sort of thing, but I am thinking more in terms of um
uh like to lose always has had a concern for fascism, right? And you know, like the fascistic life is just
not as good as the non-fascistic life and like constantly overcoming the mini fascisms of of one
life is a constant endeavor or like sadness, right? I mean, the sad life is not the good life
the sad life where I'm not capable of being affected or affecting others isn't just is like
a worse life, you know, not from a moral like um authoritative standpoint, but it is
kind of a shitty life. Yeah, yeah, I mean there are better and worse modes of living. I mean according
to both Nietzsche and Deleuze and I don't think that's like a bad thing to say that there are better and
work like well I think Nietzsche I don't I don't think Nietzsche has a problem saying that at all
I don't think that that's the kind of thing that Deleuze says. I mean he doesn't say it, no not outright
so so he's he's a lot um a lot more hesitant. I mean despite the fact that they'll make all kinds of
very provocative claims. I mean for instance one of the things that I found interesting here: do you guys
remember a couple of sessions ago when I was like it was the humor or no it was the three images of the
philosophers and I was like look I get why the transcendence is a problem but I don't get why
the descent is a problem and here you see he's like the descent, you know, we spoke too quickly about the
descent stuff. In fact, we got to go back to the descent stuff. So it was this, you know, moment of it took 20
pages, but I I mean if for me I was like oh good. I was I was hooked in. I understood what was happening
because I had a resistance to the move that he made there, but he was working on a different problem
and then 20 pages later he goes oh that descent stuff we've got to you know it's not as dismissible
As I, as I thought, it was right, like, um, we must go back. This is on 143. We must go back to what we said
a little while ago to introduce some variants. We moved too quickly when we presented the stoic
challenging depth and finding there are only infernal mixtures corresponding to passion's bodies, etc., etc., and
then he spends the remainder of this chapter saying actually the question of bodies and events is more
complex than we presented it there, but it's not that it's more complex and he's getting more, it's
just that that was a different problem, yeah, you know, and and so and that's so in other words, like
the things that seem like they're the good guys and the bad guys at particular moments
will become differently different, you know, they will switch valences depending on the practice at at that
time, so it's never, I think, is simply a question of the good life, whatever that could possibly mean
but you just think about the good life representational, you can never point to it and say, right, that's a good
life, you know, imitate, like, well not imitate, but like represent those things, you know, have those same
things that uh, you know, that the that are part and parcel of the of the good life, uh, but conversely
you can only do that, right, like I mean at the same time there's nothing but the action of pointing and
saying that that's the good life, but I do think that Deleuze, unlike Nietzsche, is much more reticent to say
x is the way to go, right, it's like I mean I think that he is too invested in singularity and
singularity is impersonal, right, it is not reducible to what I want, so you know when you think about
affirming, when you talk about affirming and many people do this, it's about a consciousness saying yes to
something that is not for him what affirmation is. It's not about me saying go my life, right, um
so so it's not, I mean, because that is an operation of consciousness who has assessed uh state of
affairs and has decided, you know, that there's a whole morality to it, and and I think if anything
i mean as Nathaniel pointed out, like questioning the fascisms goes really fucking deep in in a sense I
mean this is you know Foucault's intro to Anti-Oedipus but that the the fascisms that Deleuze is interested
in is the really really subtle ways in which we moralize uh in in the very act of thinking not
just when we say that sucks that's good but when when we say I or they in this case is a is a major
target here, but even if affirmation isn't con I mean just to clarify affirmation is some sort of
change in your disposition even if it's not like you said a conscious uh like I'm affirming
becoming I mean we've got our shit let's go ahead but I'm just saying in order to affirm
becoming wouldn't that require some that requires a phase shift at least and maybe it's not conscious
maybe let me phrase it this way the the problem in order to affirm already presumes that there's an
alternative, right, like it's not like affirming becoming as a choice as opposed to another choice
you know conscious or not, you know, that there is only the affirmation of becoming. Well, but what
what about I mean but resentment is not that? Yeah, absolutely. Affirmation of becoming only functions
again imminent to resentment, right, before I mean imminent to not before, you know, I'm not after not prior
I mean that's my take on it is it's not it's not temporally before and it's not like
um it's not having done with resentment writ large, it's it's figuring out sort of micro ways and not
figuring out because that just is too consciousness laid but like uh coming up with ways of um in in
local moments of making resentment function differently, like of finding that sort of finding again the
secret but finding the singular dimensions within any given practice at any given moment and that's all that
it that's all that it can be, you know, it can't ever now of course you can you could imaginably hook up
coordinates such that like playing music with this group of people tends to hook well in ways that with
this other group it doesn't, right, like I mean you know, and then you form a band or you do whatever you
you become a basketball team or whatever else, right, like so so there are always those components of it
but it is nevertheless like you're not overcoming at least in my version there's no overcoming of
certainly recognition or resentment for humans there's just not um they're figuring out particular
ways and instances in which it doesn't doesn't operate the same way I guess I'm just still curious about
like what at what register this ethical not demand but ethical inquiry functions like are we trying to
like in the terms of this series or the previous series are we trying to turn represent or
kind of morph representation into expression so that it's kind of you know what I mean like where
our representation is to understand the relationship between representation and an expression and to understand the representation
has no value without the expression of the sense which you know in terms of like a moral imperative would
Have to look something a whole lot more like in direction which would say like all right i'm, you know
Like i i'm always sort of like, you know, pointing out or recognizing or doing the resentment thing
But uh at the same time i'm also doing the affirmation thing at a different level, and those things never
totally speak to each other so like if i'm going to engage you know the good life then i have to deal
with representations of it or moralizations of it or whatever else but i'm all but like i think affirmation
comes down to like like in so far as affirmation becomes a will then it's sort of like
the indirection of saying all right i'm dealing with you know this is these images of the good life
so as to provoke something else that has nothing to do with those images um so the yeah and i think
that so the critique of Hegel would be he only exists at one level right like he only exists at this sort
of phenomenal phenomenal level and that there is another level which is that of singularity and primary
difference that is operative within so that's the sense in which Hegel's of course never wrong
about anything he's also missing everything about everything you know that both of those he's missing
the sense and he can't but in so far as the whole thing is driven by consciousness and recognition
good sense isn't something you could ever recognize right you can always become the object of a
recognition but then the sense in which that other sense has been like as soon as you take up the
sense as an object of recognition then that operation is expressing a new sense
which i mean again for me one of the major upshots of that is that's why you can't get a moralism out
of this you know or i mean of course you can right but you know anyone can but the idea of a delusian
morality like that how is to lose teaching us to live is he's not right like uh or not any more than the
staff blow does um or not any more or less you know that that's why he likes the sort of nonsense of the
stoic sage is because it's like you'll never you know what what's the the stuff with the eggs is like
and if the master has to do the whole egg thing himself then the student's just not going to
learn right like and that's just like taking apart an egg right yeah but let's look at let's look at
that passage on the Bousquet stuff to my inclination for death which was a failure of the will i will
substitute a longing for death which would be the apotheosis of the will that's the quote from this
inclination to this longing there is in a certain respect no change except a change of the will a sort
of leaping in place of the whole body which exchanges its organic will for a spiritual will it wills now
not exactly what occurs but something in that which occurs something yet to come which would be
consistent with what occurs in accordance with the laws of an obscure humorous conformity the event
right it is in this sense that the amor fati is one with the struggle of free men
right how do i affirm so it's that's that's the thing is distinguishing between the state of
affairs and the event that is a dimension of the state of affairs
so i mean in terms of the Hegel thing it would be that Hegel can't think the event
or singularity yeah or difference yeah i mean i i do get it in terms of like the relationship between
them but i'm still a little like uh i don't know i i just well it doesn't really matter my reservations
right now don't really matter that's all right yeah the event is not what occurs an accident it is
rather inside what occurs the purely expressed yeah it signals and awaits us in accordance with the three
proceedings is become the man of your learn to embody their perfection and brilliance by the way i
i i mean i also should say like um that there's another part earlier where i just wrote next to
it like this is how i've been thinking of style all the time which is this sort of the idea of styles
being dispositional inclinations that kind of inhabit us periodically right like that that going through
your day means like and not that you are taking on it's that they're taking on you right like um and
there there was just a couple moments like on 146 147 identifying with the quasi cause which is the you
know the event is the quasi cause the sage wishes to give a body to the incorporeal effect since the
effect inherits inherits the cause Goldschmidt puts it very well with respect to an event such as going for
a walk the walk incorporeal insofar as it is a way of being acquires a body under the effect of the
hegemonic principle which is manifested in it so that's just going for a walk right that's not
a philosopher going for a walk you know it's just the walk is incorporeal it's a disposition
that gets embodied in sometimes in some people who go for walks you know yeah
and this applies to the wound and to archery as much as the stroll
the um yeah the stuff about the wound and the cutting into the depths of the body was interesting
to me yeah and at first I was thinking it was kind of it was it was uh surprising to use that language
for me with the loose because it felt like it was at first subjectivizing the whole ontological
framework right because like a wound happens to somebody but in reality the wound is pre-individual
right here so that it makes a little more sense where the wound actually allows for the body to
exist. The wound does not happen to a person, you know, it's it's actually the parameters of the body
in some ways right because it's the the cutting up of the undifferentiated body which is what the event
does right is also creates that play of surfaces where now these bodies are able to relate to each
other but I mean think of that think of it in to me in the sort of simplest terms which is if the
ethics is to become um to become worthy I think is that worthy right not become on to not be on not
the unworthy of what happens to us so like you get you get hurt how do you deal with that I'm hurt I'm
hurt it's always we always think of it so how would how would one become worthy of that well to think
that I only exists in order for that wound to have taken place to me I can't think of any other way
of imagining what it would be to be worthy of a wound other than to put yourself on a lower place in
relationship to the wound right and say like oh I was the occasion for that to enact itself now when you if
you make that shift then you start thinking oh there's a terrain of life of impersonal life called
wounds called whatever happens that's way more interesting than say mine right like my body is
simply the occasion for the for those lives and that's I mean that I think heads towards the direction of
what it might mean to to be worthy of of the things that happen to us right yeah yeah I mean becoming
then would just be a a series of wounds a perpetual series of wounds and deaths right that that never
end there's no final burn their death yeah self-transformation transformation right yeah
right yeah exactly right yeah right so we're just an opportunity for wounds to happen
you